Now that we have a better idea
of what makes up Sunshine,
let's talk about the ideal state
where a production-quality
Android app should be.
While it's easy to immediately dive into
the minutiae, let's take a step back and
look at the big picture.
What are the goals of
an amazing Android app?
It actually starts with create
a vision for all of Android.
Create a vision for Android.
And all Android apps
have three main pillars.
Enchant Me, Simplify My Life,
and Make Me Amazing.
Enchant Me revolves around the idea
that your app should both look and
act effortlessly,
through well-placed animations and
a feeling that the app was designed
specifically for the user.
Simplify My Life involves making
the app easy to understand.
Whether it's for a new user just trying
to figure out what exactly your app
does, or a returning user,
where you're trying to make the
experience as frictionless as possible.
Make Me Amazing is about leveraging the
strengths of Android to build apps that
contribute to building a whole
greater than the sum of its parts.
Integrating into one another, and
extending beyond a single entry point
app, you need to remember to
launch to get any benefit.
Many of these concepts
shouldn't be foreign to you.
Making a great experience for
users should always be in
the forefront of your thoughts.
Let's take a look at Sunshine to see
exactly where we are with each of these.